well tonight we gonna party to the party
don't stop and the party don't stop
because it keeps on going non-stop gonna
party all night gonna keep this party
going cause the party won't stop
[Music]
hey what's up Ted in the net come on in
yes all right thanks for coming
have a bloody good time awesome oh oh
there he is what's up Noah Michael
Jackson
hey
[Music]
hey
ow nice oh some oh there we go there we
go
all right three is the shark four all
right well Annie are you okay oh he's
leaning he's leaning are you okay all
right are you okay Andy are you okay
Annie you've been touched by a smooth
criminal oh
more kicks more closer girls to your
face
no more you want to come inside
that's annoying that is very annoying
stop stop
don't do it anymore
just keep doing the Shimon that's where
the children
that's in bad taste
this isn't don't even know what that is
Thriller eyes
what are you doing do you ever know what
jamming Island no you cut off oh okay he
doesn't slap his ass like that so I
don't know what okay
hey
stop stop it stop it stop it
the costumes awful the impression is
stupid and played out everybody and
their mother was Michael Jackson three
years ago when he died
you died
oh
wait wait wait he died oh Noah
oh no
what no wait wait a second don't stand
and walk away
happy Halloween and now we have a
special treat hold on to your yamakas
okay from east to west you know they're
the best getting you in the zone for
your Milestone is that cute please
welcome gavalta fresh and Dr dreidels
[Music]
all right
when you see black people at a bar
mitzvah it's very exciting it's like a
scary ride and the kids just love it
right now we are the number one boss
slash Bob Mitch for party motivators and
all in Nassau County I mean you got the
bot missiles yeah always to men you know
all of them coming through like a villa
with the Recycled dress and I mean the
hoods but these guys with the cocktail
stick it's it's a real Shonda what it's
supposed to be Simka yeah yeah it's
supposed to be a Simcoe just really
can't put a price on the look on your
child's face when they see a black
person for the first time
that's just magical really
is he getting back up or what we are not
technically chosen we're chosen by the
choseness which is kind of better than
being just the chosen that's right it's
less responsibility Jews are like black
people but we were black people before
there were black people
um although I guess that's not true they
were just in a different part of the
world they're all black people coming to
get me help
[Music]
inside
spiritually intoxicating
you find it culturally fascinating
and we find it monetarily exhilarated
when we say Sarah you say Schwartzman
Sarah Sarah
I mean the fact that we're willing to
put forth the extra time is what sets us
apart I mean how often is a 13 year old
gonna hear their own name
we learned that name
we rehearse it
Judaism can be a very somber religion
that's right you know something we
learned along the way is that the word
ghetto
means something very different to these
people
so I was a little nervous about the
whole thing and no not because they were
black but
because you never really know what those
kind of people are gonna do
if we can add some fun some life some
color to a Jewish person's life when
they're still young they might not grow
up and run away from black people when
they see them maybe they won't or uh
fire people so willy-nilly
when they're older
[Music]
we provide a service to these people
[Music]
bodies
that's what we do
that's what we do we motivate parties
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody focus on look this party
tonight could be a model for the way
that the world should work
and I just want to say
I'm totally stoked to the max about it
all right you guys feeling good oh yeah
Dennis what are you shooting video yeah
man all right well be careful with that
I might run for office someday
now trust me I think that this party can
be
the most inspirational party this campus
has ever seen is that coming to me and
just grab that
[Music]
it's a racial spot some righteous but we
got going on there we need some
Bodacious jock Vapes coming in yeah we
need some hot ass punk rock babes I I
don't care where they come from the most
important thing it's imperative that we
have a diversity in the uh [ __ ]
Department intercepted I don't sleep on
burial
don't ever sleep on burial
that is some major dobage
[Music]
apartheid is totally gnarly
it's a gnarly institution where is he
Dennis that there we go come over here
get this get this okay we gotta have a
system in place to get everybody weed
all right so just watch this is how
you're gonna do it all right this this
is I'm really Frosty right now by the
way this is your Constitution all right
it's just a piece of paper we got to
keep its Integrity because it's going to
hold everything together this right here
this is us this is the American people
we're special we're magic hello yay yay
we all live in here all right the most
important thing is that we don't get too
far apart I mean you we got to be close
that's that's the magic of America's
love otherwise we're gonna get air
bubbles in there it's gonna start
canoeing and everything we don't want
that all right you get that all right
look
my way ahead of you but I'm already done
boom fireworks Fourth of July that's for
you we want like 10 of these
[Music]
what was I saying
to the man of the hour
guys
best bachelor party ever
oh yeah
yeah I can still do it all right Bella
yes what do you say we get a stripper
yes
Dre I told you man no strippers uh is
this a bachelor party or isn't it I'm
your best man there's no way I'm gonna
let you puss out on your own bachelor
party we getting a stripper and we gonna
connect the dots yes connect the dots
yeah Tinker toy it man you're behind her
and then we all
we go to town
dude you know you're up front then
game on
hold up hold up hold up hold up no
what's the yeah yeah what is that guys
this is Tommy's last night of Freedom
what's up though
you know
okay okay when you say
are we what are we are we all Linked UP
yeah baby elephant walk
okay okay okay
um
are you saying that that we would we
would all be each other
you don't understand us oh dude okay
look here it is okay you're a girl right
right right yeah then we said right
there right there yeah what the [ __ ] I'm
not doing that you guys
Tommy's about to walk the plank of
marriage all right this is our last
chance Last Chance for what I'm not
gonna [ __ ] a guy yeah no dude we'd all
be the girl okay yeah
together
right there right that's the weird part
okay I get it I get it you don't want to
be disrespectful to women I get that
okay the issue forget the girl Armenian
conveyor belt just the groom and his
groomsmen
kept the part that nobody wants
yeah I definitely don't want to have sex
with any of you guys yeah you're killing
my buzz guys what the [ __ ] man this is
supposed to be Tommy's last big
celebration no judgment judgment is not
what is keeping us from each other geez
forget it no I'm saying guys if you
listen to my words Tommy's in here
stripper we're in the other room
the rest of us is just
hey
[Music]
well tonight
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
Facebook Party Time skin tight jeans
Friday nights dance dance dance cause
tonight we're going out and we ain't
coming back cause the party won't stop
and we'll go all night Friday night
every night
[Music]
[Music]
Friday night every
[Music]
New York City LA Chicago Houston Philly
San Diego Phoenix Austin Fort Worth
Boston Memphis Denver Portland Vegas
Tucson Fresno Akron Tampa Pittsburgh
newer Plano Lincoln love it Durham Salem
Dayton city city city
[Music]
party party
[Music]
so tonight we're gonna party till the
Party Don't Stop
let's go
here is your white one thank you you are
welcome hey Pete a little uh a little
thirsty tonight
yeah super thirsty Pete this is eraser
all right so this is uh Pete aresa just
got back from Africa oh wow Africa
uh where was I oh the AUC oh right so
this conflict is exactly the reason the
African Union commission was put in
place to address the organization of
African Unity certainly wasn't going to
do anything exactly and in Coast design
at La mini Zuma wants to do anything
about bangui she's certainly been quiet
about it the worst part about fungi is
that no one knows what's going on oh no
I mean look at right next door the South
Sudan here's the thing everybody just
thinks that it's like it's the damn Lion
King over there you know Lion King
excuse me
it's not the Lion King
exactly
I mean what do people think
and Boone is gonna hold a lion cub
over a rock
to the sun while all the little animals
sing
[Music]
anyway
um something else I wanted to mention is
they have the Manpower because Amazon
has 25 000 troops just sitting there in
Somalia it's not a three animated hyena
situation that doesn't make any sense
the bad guy isn't scar
over there
um yeah yeah that's right it's not like
Scar's the bad guy huh well I mean you
know the truth is no
blame
in reality Amazon doesn't have that much
control I don't like Simba
oh like Simba he had no control over
well he was plucked out from his home
and went on a whole journey before he
came back and was just in the middle of
a war really had nothing to do with him
you know Pete I'd be really interested
in hearing your thoughts on the un's
policies in East Africa
[Music]
Hakuna Matata
unbelievable
yes
oh my God that sums it up perfectly
there's so much work still to be done
yes that's what I was saying it's been
going on for so many years so many years
circle of life
exactly that's really brilliant
I remember brilliant let's dial it back
I'm just a man okay uh I'm gonna
I'm gonna go get some uh some hors
d'oeuvres okay no need to announce it
[Music]
hey did you see that look at that look
like Buster Rhymes and Maya Angelou had
a baby
yeah yeah that was one jacked up looking
[Laughter]
uh oh you just dropped the n-word but
you're not an N lucky for you there's a
way to avoid these situations
introducing the new smartphone
application the knee graph finally a
technology specifically designed to help
you determine whether or not you can
drop the n-bomb I can say it
we can all say it
not in this lifetime to see your knee
graph just enter your name age and color
of your skin or just the color of your
skin I've got the knee graph on my phone
and my iPad my phone says I can't ever
say it my iPad says I can never say it
but bigger the negrath can you say the
n-word I can say all day long
[Music]
I'd like to but it says we're right here
the knee graph
[Music]